if you want to call into the show but
you want to leave me a message as
opposed to talk to me live
you can call literally any time of day 3
am as many people call in
2 p.m whenever you can call 219
to david p and you can leave a voicemail
here's a voicemail about um
in i guess we would call them
inter-political
relationships relationships between left
and right wingers
take a listen to this hey david quick
question
do you think you could date or marry
a good faith conservative not one of
these cuid on people
um do you think because i know bill
maher talked about this on his show one
time
about i can't think of the couple but
one of them was a republican strategist
and the husband was a liberal strategist
democratic strategist
but from what i understand they were
both you know reasonable people they
weren't you know
one of them wasn't crazy right-wing
lunatic or crazy loved one
do you think you could date a pretty
much middle-of-the-road
reasonable um intelligent
conservative or or no yeah so listen um
i this is this is a good question
uh i i once did date a conservative
sort of but at the time i didn't know
she was a conservative at the time she
really wasn't a conservative her family
was and
politics just weren't on my radar i
think had that relationship lasted
um it would not have worked because it
was pretty wacky brand of conservatism
but but beyond that you know
as an adult it's hard to imagine i mean
listen i think if if you want to come up
with a sort of uh
conservative who like thinks taxes
should be lower than i think they should
be
and doesn't think medicare for all is
the right way to arrange health care and
can sort of like reasonably defend it
but they're not
homophobic or anti-abortion i mean i
think that a lot of the social issues
would be tougher because
in a um in a social context that starts
to become
weird and awkward and i would also
question
a lot of the social things like you you
can think taxes should be lower than i
think they should be
but more or less have a moral framework
that is in line with mine
it's hard for me to imagine someone
who's homophobic
anti-abortion extremely religious
and um you know thinks
creationism should be taught in science
class who otherwise
is going to share my values in a way
that wouldn't be a problem so i i guess
what i'm saying is
if the differences are economic to some
degree
or or something like that it seems like
that would not be a problem relationship
wise but
but going beyond that i think would be
extremely difficult
we have a great bonus show for you today
manhattan will stop
prosecuting prostitution and will
dismiss cases dating back decades very
interesting decision made there
a governor k ivy of alabama has signed a
bill
allowing college athletes to monetize
their name image and likeness very
interesting in terms of what it will do
uh in a number of different ways for
athletes in alabama
and joe biden as i mentioned earlier is
calling for every employee to get paid
leave for vaccinations and in fact
putting in place a tax credit for
employers to allow
employees to get paid to be paid
have paid leave i think better said to
go and get vaccinated will this move the
needle
we'll talk about that and more on the
bonus show how do you get access to the
bonus show
two ways number one become a member at
joinpakman.com
easy quick you'll be listening or
watching listening to or watching the
bonus show in under a minute
second option patreon
become a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show i will see you then